[Music]
okay
[Music]
i'm just heading out on a little morning
walk i try to do this every day
i do a morning walk and then a walking
tattoo
and it's just a nice way to like start
the day got my coffee
and trying not to eat my hair because
it's kind of windy out
look at these clouds so interesting
[Music]
these right here they look so pretty
right they almost look fuzzy but they're
so dangerous
i've gotten them stuck down in my leg
and on my foot and in my shoe and yeah
if you ever come across these pay
attention
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to the desert welcome to my
office
so uh today is a work day i need to
answer emails and catch up on socials
um upload a few things and do some
financial stuff the main thing i want to
talk about today
is internet some of you have asked how
do you get internet in the van
it's pretty simple i just use my phone
to hotspot my laptop
so i use verizon and i have an unlimited
data
talk and text plan and it's about 90 a
month
and i believe it includes 30 gigabytes
of hotspot
so i've only run out once i figured out
why
is because i accidentally had my
creative cloud um
automatically updating whenever i would
connect to my hotspot and that drained
it one time
otherwise i find that i have more than
enough to like stream netflix
um upload even to youtube although i've
only done that a few times
and do everything social media and email
related when i moved into the van
i found i had way worse service it might
be the metal or the insulation or
something like that places where i used
to get four bars in my suv
i'd suddenly have one or two in the van
so i recently
installed a weboost drive range cell
booster
it has an outdoor antenna that picks up
a signal and sends it to the interior
antenna which then broadcasts to my
phone
the installation was pretty easy i wound
up routing the wire
under the weather ceiling in the back
door and down into the bench where the
box lives
and then connecting to the interior
antenna where i can easily plug and
unplug the box when i need it the bench
cushions hide the wires and i can still
get inside the bench to make my bed
easily i may end up doing a more
permanent installation down the road but
this works for now
okay so you can see here i have just one
bar of lte
and then i just have to plug in the dc
charger so now you can see i have three
bars
oh four bars even better another thing i
like to do when i roll up to a new
location
is test the internet speed using this
app called speed test
it will tell you just how much your
upload and download speed is
so you that's pretty high that's
more than enough to get most of my work
done another option is to purchase a
wi-fi device from your carrier and load
it with a certain amount of
internet my only experience with this is
when i was living
or traveling overseas and it worked
pretty great here in the states i just
use my phone because
your phone essentially works as a
hotspot so you actually need service in
order for the wi-fi device to work so
it's kind of the same thing
at least that's my understanding so
aside from my hotspot and signal booster
um i usually pop into libraries and
coffee shops
so i did that way more before covid
obviously hopefully things will get back
to normal soon
you can find really great wi-fi options
like whole foods
starbucks mcdonald's most cafes even
visitor centers
i hope those pointers were helpful i
have to get back to work
i have to update my budget and travel
expenses i haven't done that in a really
long time
so yay really exciting afternoon
you are my favorite place to go
you're
[Music]
one thing i love about living on the
road is
opening the door and being instantly
outside
[Music]
stones
i love the ground
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you